I mean it really is amazing Ellen
DeGeneres is starting off the new decade
with a huge honor oh my god this is
wonderful the talk-show icon is
receiving the carol burnett award at the
2020 golden globe
[Applause]
the award which is decided by the
Hollywood Foreign Press is for those who
have made outstanding contributions to
TV on or off screen and that certainly
sounds like Ellen I guess it's a
comeback woman of the year I came out I
went away and I'm back
in 1997 the stand-up comedian broke
boundaries on her TV series Ellen are
you coming out or not yeah like quit
jerking us around it come out already
when both her character and Ellen
herself came out as gay I mean why can't
I just see the truth I mean be Who I am
I'm 35 years old I'm so afraid to tell
people I mean I just Susan I'm gay I
think that most of my fans knew or
assumed that I was gay or and and I
think respected my right to my privacy
and my choice to come out or not I think
what people now feel is that they really
respect the fact that that I have done
that and they haven't wavered on their
support of me it's only it's only made
them I think appreciate how difficult
that was for me you know and so I get I
get a tremendous amount of support from
from the live audience Ellen wanted to
connect with that live audience even
more so in 2003 she launched the Ellen
DeGeneres Show I love talking to people
I love thinking on my feet I love not
knowing what's gonna happen next and and
meeting interesting people every day and
and staying home and and going home to
my own house every night and having a
job five days a week is I mean
everything about it as appealing to me
I've uh I've always wanted to do a talk
show and over the past 17 seasons
she's won 31 Daytime Emmys about a year
ago Jim Perry Tori was trying to
convince station managers that people
still wanted to see me on television and
I thank you
[Applause]
for watching I can't believe I'm even
here I didn't think this was even
possible to be invited back to this so I
should have been a day time a long time
ago I love this it was the hardest thing
that I ever had to do in my life and I
would not change one moment of it
because it led me to be exactly where I
am today standing in front of all of you
Ellen is only the second recipient to be
honored with the Carol Burnett award
following on the heels of Carol Burnett
herself at the 2019 ceremony you have to
embrace all the moments in life because
they all add to something that makes you
a better person
[Music]